good day uh my name is dawn tipping i'm
here at
siskiyou seeds in our propagation
greenhouse and i wanted to share
a few uh tips for guidance on what you
could be planting right now we're in a
bit of a transition time
in between the spring cool season crops
of the greens and the roots and the warm
season crops where
here in oregon it's too cold still to be
planting things like
corn and melons and squash outside
but you could be starting some of them
inside so we've been getting a few
questions through email and at the
market and stuff
of people planting cucumbers outside and
they're saying my seeds aren't coming up
and i wanted to share this idea of soil
temperature so for
all the cool season crops they can
germinate in cool soils
down to about 40 degrees fahrenheit they
can still grow in warmer soils
lettuce would be an exception of about
70 degrees
lettuce is not going to germinate very
well so all your greens
they like growing in the cooler weather
so lettuce
cabbage arugula spinach swiss chard
chinese cabbage there's a bunch of other
ones broccoli
cauliflower that type of thing kale and
your root crops
they like to grow in the cool weather of
the spring
or in the fall is when you get the best
quality on your root crops they will
grow through the summer
but they're going to do better if you
start them in the spring and then
peas would be a fruiting crop that you
can plant in the spring or the fall but
they don't really
do well in the heat of the summer so
moving on to the warm season crops these
are crops
that are they can frost
if you plant them outside so not only
will
they do they need warm temperatures to
sprout
they also need warm temperatures to grow
because for instance
corn and squash for that matter these
are crops that
originated in mesoamerica so they're
used to a subtropical climate
so they want to sprout and keep growing
in warm weather
so here in the temperate latitudes like
here we're at 42 degrees north latitude
and we have to wait
until the soil and the air temperatures
warmed up and obviously the air
temperature influences the soil
temperature so consider
like today is a nice balmy day it's
probably 70 degrees outside
but at night it gets down to the high
30s or around 40.
so if you average those out 12 hours of
each your soil temperature is not going
to be anywhere near
warm enough to sprout these things so
you want to think about that a quick a
hack that you can
employ let's say you really want to get
a jump start on things
and you can look over here this is a
little trick we use
is we'll start corn this is early
planting of sweet corn
in soil blocks and you can see it's
already sprouting we didn't
have any supplemental heat other than
the sun
to get these to sprout another one would
be this basil
you know so we're growing starch of the
basil here inside because it's a little
warmer here and it protects them from
frust for us
we want to wait until after late
may to be planting any of the frost
hardy crops either in the ground or
transplanting outside
and that is pretty much over most of the
northern
parts of the united states and you gotta
check your local climate
memorial day weekend is a bit of the the
green light time for when you can get
your garden in
so check around with your neighbors the
experienced gardeners and find out what
the local planting date is for your area
but i notice that we get warm days and a
lot of novice gardeners are just ready
to plant everything and then they're
frustrated
at their their poor results and they'll
blame the seed
or something they'll say slugs got my um
my plants or my seeds when the the
actuality of it all was that the soil
temperature was too cool and their seeds
rotted in the ground
so hopefully that helps you out and
you're able to be more successful with
growing more your own
food thanks